we're going to begin this hour with
startling new coronavirus numbers and a
reported wrinkle in pfizer's smoothly
laid out vaccine plans
the u.s surpassed 14 million confirmed
cases yesterday
a day when there were more than 217 000
new cases and more than 276
000 people fellow americans alive on
january 1st have since
died of the virus with the higher
highest daily
death toll yesterday than we've had ever
before
that's not good according to the wall
street journal pfizer ran into a supply
issue last month and had to cut in half
the number of doses that it planned to
distribute the company still expects to
roll out more than a billion doses
worldwide in 2021
vaccinations start in the uk this month
in a cbs news interview
with major garrett yesterday dr anthony
fauci criticized that country's plans
while also praising the fda
they really rushed through that approval
the fda the united states of america
food and drug administration
is the gold standard of regulation
they're doing it in a very careful way
appropriately in the meantime
president-elect joe biden now says he
plans to ask all of us to wear a mask
for his first 100 days
in office he also wants to require mask
wearing in certain places like
federal buildings chief washington
correspondent major garrett joins us to
discuss his interview with dr
fauci and this week's political
headlines major good morning good
morning
dr apache has since walked back his
comments to you
about the uk rushing to approve a
vaccine he told the bbc
uh he has great faith in health
officials there
but he clearly was concerned about it he
was and you can't walk back
as definitive a statement as dr fauci
made to me which is
their process is different than ours
ours is more rigorous
in dr fauci's words not mine he said the
brits essentially looked at the pfizer
data from a press release
and approved the vaccine the food and
drug administration does not do that
it goes to the underlying data
scrutinizes everything before it gives
emergency use authorization and then i
also asked him i said well the head of
the fda has been brought to the white
house twice this week by the chief of
staff mark meadows
do you consider that to be overt
political pressure dr fauci said no
it's about explaining the fda process
and getting white house backing of that
i said would it help in that context for
the white house to put out a statement
saying exactly that dr fauci said it
would
i guess we'll all wait for that major
president-elect biden has already
made a point of of asking dr fauci to
stay on
as his chief medical advisor how
significant do you think that is
it's important and the most important
thing that happened yesterday revealed
also on my show
is that yesterday for the first time via
zoom
the transition landing team for
president-elect biden met with
dr fauci and all of his team i said how
often do you expect those conversations
to go on he said
almost on a daily basis from now on in i
said would you prefer that those
conversations have occurred
and started sooner he said of course
every transition that begins earlier is
a better one but we are where we are
let's talk about the president's
baseless claims so far about
widespread voter fraud even attorney
general bill barr
said well that's not exactly the case is
his job safe it's not exactly reassuring
when the
when you're asked about the president
says well ask me in a few
weeks well a few weeks is inauguration
day number one
number two the senate and the house are
trying to race through
three enormous legislative priorities in
about a week and a half
is there going to be a stimulus bill to
deal with covid19 are we going to keep
the government open and operating are we
going to
pass the national defense authorization
act all three are very important and
you're seeing republicans move away from
the president's position
on all three of those that suggests
they're already thinking about how to
deal with the post-trump reality
even though the president is not and on
that basis
also lindsey graham a staunch defender
of the president said yesterday
where's the evidence well when bill barr
and lindsey graham are walking away from
you president trump you know you have
very few allies left in washington
and you better start thinking
differently about what you're asserting
and trying to allege
yeah do you think bill barr's job is
safe major
it probably not as not as safe as it was
a week ago but what's the what's the
point
you're going to sack your attorney
general and then what the senate is
going to confirm a new one no
you're just leaving the attorney
generalship vacant and
the department of justice rudderless and
leadership-less
is that really the way you want to go
out mr president i mean it could happen
i'm not ruling it out
but what's the point there really isn't
a governing point whatsoever
other than the president expressing his
rage as someone who won't do precisely
what he wants him to do
even though the job of the attorney
general is to apply the law
as it's written not as the president
wants it to be interpreted major
meanwhile the president's headed to
georgia tomorrow as he continues
his claims of voter fraud there are a
lot of concerns among republicans
that he may be suppressing the party's
own vote there
right he'll run up the vote in the rural
areas where the trump supporters believe
he's onto something but he could very
likely suppress it in the suburban areas
where the republicans don't buy this
assertion made over and over without any
backing that there is something wrong in
the way georgia conducted its election
and that's a tension that is playing
itself out there it's got republicans
attention here they want the president
to stop and give a unified message
look elect these two republicans back
their agenda i'm with them
and set aside his grievances about
george's
election conduct they will all wait to
see
what he does what's the constant here
the president's at the center of the
spotlight
where he always wants to be major
garrett thank you major